my question to you is which of these two
values is greater 22.9
or the square root of 0.45
and i encourage you to first try to see
if you could think about this without a
calculator and then use a calculator to
see what what which one is larger
so let's first try to do it without a
calculator so one thing that you could
try to say is well look z you could say
that
22.9
that's going to be less than i'm just
going to pick an arbitrary an arbitrary
number here let's say that's less than
30 percent
so that's going to be less than and i
picked 30 because it's easy to calculate
30 percent or the square of 30 percent
so that's less than
30 percent or it's another way of saying
that's less than 0.3
0.3 and then we could try to compare 0.3
to this thing here and if 0.3 is less
than this
well then 22.9 percent is going to be
less than this because it's less than
0.3 so why don't i why don't i change
the problem to that let's compare 0.3
0.3
to square root
to the square root of let me do that
same pink color
to the square root of 0.45
and now i could use the squaring
technique what happens if i square each
of these quantities
if i square this 0.3 times 0.3 let's see
3 times 3 is 9 but you're multiplying
two things that each have one digit to
the right so you're going to have two
digits to the right so it's going to be
0.9 and if you were to square this over
here
i'll just keep using the white if you
were to square this right over here
what's that going to be well that's just
going to be 0.45
so 0.9 is clearly less than 0.45
or 0.3 squared is clearly less than
square root of 0.5 0.3 squared is less
than the square root of 0.5
0.45 squared and so we know that 0.3 is
going to be less than
is going to be less than the square root
of 0.45
and so now we can say that 22.9 percent
if it's less than this and this is less
than this well then 22.9 percent must be
less than that now another way you could
do it you could take out a calculator
you could take out a calculator i'll do
that just just for kicks
so i'm going to get the calculator out
so 22.9 percent that's the same thing as
that's the same thing as
0.229
so we really just want to compare this
quantity to the square root of 0.45 and
there's two ways we can do it we could
do the way i started we could square
this and see if it's greater than
0.45
so let's do that you could just square
it and you see no it's zero this is zero
point this is 0.05 which is clearly less
than 0.45 and so that would validate
this or you could do it the other way
around you could just use your
calculator to calculate the square root
of this
so you could say
0.45
and then take the square root
the square root of this value right over
here is approximately is approximately
0.67
so this is
this thing right over here is
approximately 0.67
which is approximately 67 percent which
is clearly greater than 22.9 percent so
a bunch of ways that you could approach
it it is nice to be able to estimate
things think in your head so that if you
didn't have access to a calculator you
could get a general sense of hey you
know would you rather have a 22.9 off
the price of something or maybe maybe
some type of new store could say hey
sales square root of 0.45 off of all
goods i don't know
that could be an interesting thing could
be very confusing for for customers but
anyway hopefully this was helpful